some breaking news betty white just
passed oh no way betty white she didn't
make it to 100 she was gonna be a
hundred in january just passed
are we that surprised fellas
apparently the youngest guy here is
surprised so he's david you okay
podcast that's brutal though to announce
that 99 year old and betty white it's
like american by the way don't forget
harry reid as well harry on his behalf
john madden and betty white and that's
what people do man betty right
they died yeah
actually full disclosure i thought john
madden passed years ago bro are you
being sarcastic i'm not even joking how
dare you bro
i haven't seen john madden live in
decades this was the wildest thing
that's ever happened truth when i found
out john madden died like i was sad and
my brain is telling me yeah my brain is
like bro you've never met this guy like
but my heart is like yeah in the video
games the boys yeah i felt like my uncle
passed herself do you know the magic
story do you know the madden story like
how it happened when he first signed
like they're gonna say we're gonna make
a game after you i know i know he was
like i get like he was like kind of
hesitant he was like yeah
he's gonna be big and then [ __ ] so
the guy says hey
buy the stocks okay we're going to give
you the opportunity to buy the stocks he
calls us the greatest mistake of his
lifetime he says buy the stock and
john's like i don't care about buying
the stock he says come do this we're not
going to pay you but i'm telling you wow
yeah so john's like no i'm at a point
right i'm john madden pay me up front
so john goes they use his name for the
game he just gets an upfront check and
then they leave and it blows up
and then it blows up he's like holy [ __ ]
i made a big mistake well here's
apartheid which the story ends with 14
years later 14 years later he goes and
sits down good for the sports guys on
what they did with them he said he says
listen you guys been using my name we
got to make something work ea sports
says don't even worry about it we're
going to buy your name and rights you
know what they paid them for their
naming rights 100 million 150 million
wow 150 million yeah so opposed to that
tony hawk has told this story where you
know tony hawk huge video of course yeah
they made the game he has all those
friends in it before it releases the the
i don't know if it's the a sports but
they came to him and said we think this
game's gonna be pretty good man we're
just gonna pay once and he goes i was
broke at the time they go we're gonna
give you 500 000 and he goes and that's
like life changing yeah like i was
making no money and he's like nah i
think i'm just going to take my chance
and you'll give me a share of the sales
for each game like well yeah but we'll
just give you like a million or 500 now
and dude you're rich he's like no i
don't want i'll take my chance good for
him really and then how much is he more
of him oh my god hundreds of millions
he's still going man and his friends all
make money off of it too because they're
in the game they call it one of the
greatest games of all time yes the
famous story that goes in the other
direction i'm sure you guys all know is
is
the whole they went to foreign
hogan first but he went with the energy
drinks that's the way he went with the
uh the uh the blender because he's like
he's like a grill indoors this is stupid
who's ever gonna want to grill indoors
so he goes with the blender and then
they go to george foreman like ah look
you got to have this girl he's like all
right whatever put my name on it now are
they blaming kovit for betty white too
or what are we doing here
uh no cool like he's got the breaking
news cnn's like cove has the article of
it actually comedian american icon betty
white has died just weeks before
milestone birthday tmz has learned law
enforcement throughout energy passed at
her home just before 9 30 am a
trailblazer and pioneer media berry had
the longest running career of any woman
on tv prior to her death starring in
multiple shows over the last eight eight
decades
eight decades starring
starting all the way back to
1939. by the way thank you for being
here lasting i mean lasting power right
there bro
betty is perhaps the most famous for her
lead role in enrollment arizona golden
girls which ran from 1985 1992 she's
been in tons of by the way have you seen
betty white's younger picture do you
know what you're looking she's a bad guy
can you put yourself i've been older
betty white david i'm sure you want to
do it anyways just happened young betty
white you know what's [ __ ] sex in
the city is just golden girls after dark
it's just like x-rays
it's
good for her you know that she was the
face of the life settlement market
well she really because of being my i
have a business like pat does insurance
i do like something called life
settlements it's like reverse insurance
byron new delhi's favorite she was yeah
exactly she was the uh
the face of the life settlement market
for years they paid her you know an
upfront deal
right and a million bucks or whatever
and great career though well rest in
peace betty white
anybody that can last that long and
anything you got to give him respect so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you